have a scroll through the list of
upcoming 2016 releases and I bet you'll
see what I saw that is a lot of twos
threes fours and familiar franchises now
there's nothing wrong with that but if
you're anything like me then you
appreciate a new original game here's
five of those recall may be coming later
in the year than we had hoped but if
we're judging from the trailer and the
team that's developing it it should be
worth the wait recall was one of my
favorite reveals at e3 last year it
looks delightfully sci-fi you get a
robotic dog friends and there's a female
protagonist which are big pluses for me
on top of that the concept of rehoming
course which function like souls in two
different forms could be an intriguing
gameplay mechanic trailer impressions
aside the game is in development at
concept which is headed up by keiji
inafune a the veteran designer of mega
men for those worried they wouldn't be
able to play this one jutsu xbox one
exclusivity Microsoft have announced it
will arrive on PC to now as cool as
recall looks it doesn't have a release
date what does have a release date is
fire watch and verily state is tomorrow
perfect for those of you with little
patience to out for ps4 and PC by watch
is a first-person adventure game it's
from developer Campo Santo which is
headed up by jake Rodkin and Sean
Bannerman the creative leads of tell
tales Walking Dead Season one and also
staffed by nils anderssen the creative
lead of clays mark of a ninja renowned
graphic artist ali mosque who's
responsible for shaping the game's art
and visual style and a bunch of X Double
Fine developers hi which is the debut
title for its developer and publisher it
tells the story of Henry a fire lookout
assigned to a tower in Shoshone National
Forest deep within the Wyoming
wilderness you'll be dealing with
choices and consequences uncovering a
mystery and trying to keep your cool as
a shadowy figure watches your every move
yeah this one might get creepy your only
form of communication is a walkie-talkie
that connects you to your supervisor
Delilah and how you speak to her will
affect your relationship I'm guessing
you'll probably want to maintain that
one since we're talking about games that
come out tomorrow we'd better not skip
over unraveled or as I like to call it
the game that stormed its way into the
hearts of a hundred dated games
journalists unravel might seem all
adorable with its yani protagonist and
beautiful world but it's the story
steeped with sadness it begins with an
old woman in her home and of course a
ball of yarn which morphs into Yanni the
game will involve traversing a harsh
real-world landscape as a tiny yarn
person and you'll have to solve
environmental platforming puzzles in a
limbo esque fashion according to
creative director Martin sullen yani
represents love and the character
unravels as they travel away from what
they love yeah you'll want a box of
tissues handy for this one Guerrilla
Games have spent all that time since
2004 creating games that start with
Killzone now here they are in 2016 ready
to release horizons are adorned and it
looks pretty or the action role-playing
game will have you embody alloy a hunter
and archer who lives 1000 years in the
future after the apocalypse robotic
creatures roamed the desolate earth and
guerrilla games acepta style of gameplay
is going to be somewhere in between
Assassin's Creed and Skyrim you'll be
getting creative with traps arrows and
explosives to take out your enemies
while babbling and crafting and
exploring the earthen world horizon zero
dawn has been interval with a gorilla
suit 2011 our hopes are pretty high for
this one finally the beginning of April
is all set to deliver quantum break for
Xbox one Remedy Entertainment have a
pretty great name having worked on max
payne
and Alan Wake and this is set to be the
next big thing quantum break will give
you time manipulation powers and a
variety of guns to try and combat a
corporation that would prefer you to be
a whole lot less alive the gameplay will
consist of action sequences and
environmental puzzles but quantum break
gets a little more complicated than that
the gameplay is split in segments
between which an episode of the digital
series will play oh yeah there's a
separate integrated live-action TV
series while the game explores the story
of the two protagonists Jack Joyce and
Beth Wilder players will be able to make
choices as the antagonist in the
beginning of each episode of the show is
that sounds confusing to you you're not
alone but it sure will be intriguing to
see how it works let me know which of
these stack of games you're most excited
to play or if there's a favorite of
yours that I neglected to mention and I
will see you again next week